I really hope I can do it cuz they're
all depending on me I know that I must
leave the only home I've ever known and
brave the dangers of the forest saing
them before
eaten I
mean
[Music]
can
looking up at a sunny sky so shiny and
blue and there's a butterfly well isn't
that a super fantastic
[Music]
sign it's going to be a fantastic day
such marvelous Nest it's going to bring
got a pocket full of songs that I'm
going to sing and I'm ready to take on
any
hooray some super fun surprise around
each
cor just riding on a rainbow I'm going
to be okay hey I'm not giving up today
there's nothing getting in my way and if
you not knock me over I will get back up
again oh if something goes a little
wrong you can go ahead and bring it on
cuz if you're not knock me over I will
get back up
[Music]
again oh get back up
again I'm marching along I Got
Confidence I'm cooler than a pack of
pepper and I haven't been this excited
since I can't remember when I'm off on
this remarkable
Adventure just riding on a rainbow what
if it's all a big mistake what if it's
more than I can take no I can't think
that way cuz I know that I'm really
really really going to be okay hey I'm
not giving up today there's nothing
getting in my way and if KN KN be over I
will get back up again oh if something
goes a little well you can go ahead and
bring it on cuz if you not knock me over
I will get back up again
get back up
again I'm
okay and if you knock knock me over you
knock knock me over I will get back up
[Applause]
again can I really be happy I want to be
happy me me up what about me about me do
you really think I can be happy of
course it's inside you it's inside of
all of us and I don't think
it I feel
it I got this feeling inside
myones Wy I
it and
you inside your soul just open up your
heart let music take control got that
sunshine in my pocket got that good soul
in my feet I feel that hot blood in my
body when it drops ooh I Can't Take My
Eyes Off off it moving so phenomenal the
room unlock the way we rock it so don't
stop under the lights when everything
goes nowhere to hide when I'm getting
you
close when we move well you already know
go left W just
[Music]
imag can
see dance dance good creeping up on you
just dance dance dance all those things
I should do but you dance dance
dan
dancing so just dance dance
dance so just dance dance dance
feel so just dance dance dance
feel so keep
[Music]
[Applause]
dancing I can't stop
them my eyes let's do
it
stop st St I can't stop see but you when
you dance dance dance creeping up on you
so just dance dance
dance I should do but you dance dance
dance nobody so keep
dancing feeling in my
body feeling in my body stop
[Music]
feeling our new
[Applause]
Wing my friend I know her dance dance
dance
[Music]
I know it's not officially hug time yet
but now that I am queen I decree that
hug time is all the
time up
high
[Music]
woke up in the
morning is the day that I do
everything now that I'm Queen aom run
trolls they want to have
fun yeah trolls Just Want to Have
Fun just
justs just to Liv underr to get away
from the world till I had my life
Changed by a beautiful girl just need
the guts to tell her that she's the one
but you know trolls they want to have
fun oh trolls just want to have that's
all they really
[Music]
want
when the working day is done oh troll
they want to have
[Music]
fun all right Queen poppy I've prepared
an agenda for the day oh what I hope it
says singing dancing and hugging ow ow
uh isn't that what we do every day yeah
good times good times we have a good
time are the good times
youres
behind are the
[Music]
good poppy come quick it's an emergency
guy Diamond what's wrong I'm having a
baby we're on jumpsuit D I get to be a
RAR I don't want to be a big
sister
a what should I name him H how about
tiny diamond yeah yeah tiny diamond is
my name straight from my daddy's name my
whole body's made of glitter and iow it
in your face I love when I make music
and the groove is in my bones just like
myy I sit on the
Thro
[Music]
in in the
heart
[Music]
Yeah
just they just they
just they
justs
just huddle up grow grow grow now take
it easy growley Pete I feel bad for them
it looks like they got beat up by a
rainbow first things first these trolls
need some serious cheering up and we're
going to have to go top shelf oh now
when you say top shelf you don't mean
that's right we need to sing them the
most important songs in the history of
Music yes but which
ones all of them and when you say all of
them Yo I tell you what I want what I
really really want don't tell me what
you want what you really really want
I'll tell you what I want what I really
really want don't tell me what you want
what you really really want I want I
want
to let the dogs
out let the dogs
out come on come on come
[Music]
ony
PR what you doing
[Music]
tonight a good
timey
sh
you
[Music]
suck now I want you three to sit in here
and think about what you've just done
that was a crime against
music you think you've got a hide
it don't keep it on the
sh let your start move and watch the way
I do it do it see me do it like nobody
else we sing it all together sing
it it's not
[Music]
up we do it like
nobody don't you stop it don't you cry
it let me hear you see if you got to
can't tonight let me hear you waiting
for you already you know that you do it
like nobody else just sing singing
together louder than ever ever forget
everything just sing like it's what
we've been missing and they're going
to come on
Daddy Let Me He you I've been right here
where you standing been standing on the
ground and no walls are caving in all
the wall my lips St moving with the soul
I put into it and you never heard
[Music]
it it's waiting for you already you know
that you do like nobody else just sing
sing it together louder than
ever
everything play
play
beautiful I said a 1 2 3 and four let's
go everybody
get let me sing Let Me I want you to
sing from your soul I want you to reach
with your
elbow can't hear you way in the
back for you already you know that doing
like
no just sing sing it together louder
than get
[Music]
everything
everything just
[Music]
sing
Everything